a man and his son crashed while driving  down an icy Road two ambulances came one  took the father to a hospital in the  west the other took the sun to a  hospital in the East nurses rushed the  boy into surgery and the doctor said I  cannot operate on this boy he is my son  how can this be  time okay I'm almost finished writing  the sentence yeah you're transcribing  the whole riddle for us Drew what do you  have uh the doctors his mother  um that doesn't that doesn't make any  sense Drew so I I gave that answer as a  secondary answer but I said uh it's  because the doctor is the gay partner of  the injured dad assuming that no no  ladies or surgeons but I did say if the  feminists are right then it's the mom  but I I'm still going with my first  answer